foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will learn how to change the name of a
column and SQL but before we begin let
me tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple Technologies if
you're a tech geek in a continuous hunt
for latest technological friends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and don't forget to hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn now without further
Ado let's get started with our one point
agenda that is how to change the column
name and SQL so let's quickly take a
look at the syntax that we will be
following to change the column name in
SQL so the syntax is as follows we will
be using the alter and table keywords
and we will be specifying the table name
and then we will give the rename column
keyword then the old existing column
name and to the new column in which we
need to change it to so having a clear
understanding of the syntax let's try to
execute this command in the Practical
mode so let's get back to the MySQL
workbench so now we are on the MySQL
workbench let's quickly get access to
the simply learn database
there you go and now let's quickly take
a look at the column names in our
existing table
now you can see the First Column is the
employee number let's try to change that
by using the alter table
command and then
and now the rename keyword
the column name is EMP number
two
EMP ID semicolon
let's quickly execute this command
very good now let's try to execute the
select command once again and see the
output there you go now the employee
number has been changed to employee ID
so that's how you change the column name
in SQL if you have any queries regarding
any of the topics covered in this
session or if you require the resources
like the PPD and the code then do let us
know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be more than
happy to resolve all your queries at the
earliest until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here